supongamos que tenemos dos segmentos de
recta que se interceptan el segmento
v
y segmento
y supongamos que se intersectan en un
punto
y supongamos que conocemos la medida de
este ángulo la medida yo no sé por qué
aquí puse el ave déjame ponerla más
pegada al punto para que no nos estorbe
lo que hay aquí déjame ponerlo en
amarillo
ok te suponemos que nos han dado que
conocemos este ángulo ponemos que la
medida del ángulo de d
es de 70 grados dada esa información
dada únicamente es información lo que
quiero saber sin usar un transportador
cuál es la medida de los otros ángulos
queremos averiguar entonces la medida de
los ángulos se ve a y c&a
d para empezar notamos que dado que te
he dicho que son dos segmentos de recta
que se intersectan que el ángulo b
d
y el ángulo se ve
son ángulos adyacentes
son ángulos adyacentes también notamos
que si tomamos los lados externos de
estos ángulos se forma un ángulo ya no
es decir el ángulo ce
de es un ángulo llano entonces sabemos
que ángulos bdcb son adyacentes y que a
la vez forman un ángulo ya no es decir
tiene que ser suplementarios entonces el
ángulo de de y el ángulo se ve
suplementarios lo cual quiere decir que
suman 180 grados suplementarios
así que tenemos por tanto la medida del
ángulo bed más la medida del ángulo c/v
estoy escribiendo aquí la m para indicar
que es la medida del ángulo algunas
veces la gente le escribe sin la m de
medida la suma de estos ángulos es igual
a 180 grados y sabemos que el ángulo bd
esto de aquí este ángulo es igual a 70
grados entonces
la suma es tanta grados más el ángulo se
debe 180 grados
si restamos 70 grados a ambos lados
obtenemos que el ángulo
la medida del ángulo cb es igual a 110
grados simplemente reste 70 a ambos
lados hemos obtenido así que este ángulo
es igual a 110 grados interesante y aquí
fue por varios pasos pero podrías
haberlos razonados rápidamente si dice
aquí bueno este ángulo 70 grados la suma
estos dos ángulos de 180 grados entonces
este ángulo tiene que ser de 110 grados
ahora vamos a usar la misma lógica para
estimar cuál es el valor del ángulo
c&a entonces la medida del ángulo
c&a y usando el mismo razonamiento que
hicimos anteriormente podemos ver que la
suma del ángulo
y el ángulo ce de los lados externos de
estos ángulos forman un ángulo llano es
decir son ángulos suplementarios por lo
que su suma es 180 grados
entonces tenemos que la medida del
ángulo se a más el ángulo de 110 grados
tiene que ser igual a 180 grados son
suplementarios como dijimos entonces
restando 110 grados a ambos lados
obtenemos que la medida del ángulo c
es igual 180 grados menos 10 grados es
igual a 70 grados entonces hemos
obtenido que este ángulo es de 70 grados
y notamos que es exactamente igual a
este triángulo de acá que son ángulos
opuestos el ángulo sea al supuesto abed
de hecho la palabra correcta es opuestos
por el vértice yo les digo opuestos pero
en realidad se llaman opuestos por el
vértice en un futuro vídeo veremos que
ángulos opuestos por el vértice tienen
que ser iguales hemos visto que en este
caso en particular son iguales estos
ángulos pero se puede probar que en
general ángulos opuestos por el vértice
son iguales
vamos a escribir aquí abajo este nuevo
término el ángulo c
y el ángulo de ed y el ángulo de ver
estos ángulos son opuestos por el
vértice y como lo indica el término
estos ángulos se encuentran a lados
opuestos del vértice formado por el
cruce de las líneas de acuerdo con esto
observamos que ángulo se ve y ángulo
también son opuestos por el vértice
escribamos lo ángulo se ve más ángulo
también son opuestos por el vértice aquí
vemos que también se cumple lo que
decíamos que estos ángulos están
opuestos a través del vértice en este
caso la oposición es a través de un eje
vertical y en el caso anterior a través
de un eje horizontal sólo nos queda el
valor de un ángulo por calcular el
ángulo y el ángulo
ed y vemos que aquí también tenemos un
caso de ángulos opuestos por el vértice
los cuales tienden a ser iguales no tan
solo eso son exactamente iguales aunque
no podemos usar ese hecho para decir que
son 110 grados pues no lo hemos probado
por lo que usaremos los mismos
argumentos que hemos empleado el ángulo
y el ángulo ed son suplementarios los
lados externos forman un ángulo llano
entonces la suma de estos ángulos desde
ángulos
y el ángulo tiene que ser 180 grados
tenemos que el ángulo a de la medida el
ángulo aede más la medida del ángulo c
es igual a 180 grados conocemos la
medida del ángulo
que es igual a 70 grados 70 grados y
podemos obtener el ángulo a de la medida
del ángulo a ed restando 70 grados ambos
lados es igual a 110 grados 110 grados
110 grados que es lo que esperábamos si
sumas los ángulos adyacentes cuyos lados
externos forman un ángulo ya no te van a
dar 180 grados estos dos forma 180
grados estos dos formas 180 grados estos
dos forman 180 grados y estos dos
también forman 180 grados si das la
vuelta completa si dar la vuelta
completa
verás que suman 360 grados porque estás
dando la vuelta completa al círculo
70 más 110 180 70 250 más 110 es 360
grados aquí lo vamos a dejar en la
primera vez que obtenemos un resultado
interesante usando esta herramienta y en
el próximo vídeo vamos a obtener el
resultado de manera general vamos al
mismo razonamiento pero sin tener un
valor en particular como
70 grados vamos a obtener que en general
para cualesquiera ángulos cuando están
opuestos por el vértice estos son
iguales